hey it's me Tiffany Haddish and I'm here
to show you how to get it in I want you
to win when it comes to Dayton I want
you to have the best life possible
so here got some tips from me tip tip
[Music]
[Applause]
on the first date best thing to do is
restaurant because then I can figure out
what kind of eating habits this person
has and also we can have an actual
conversation now a movie is cool but
that means I don't really want to talk
to you you don't really want to hear
what I got that's like a second or third
day all right now if we got some
amusement park on a Thursday that's cool
cuz that's fun and you're gonna be
splitting the gang of money on candy and
hotdogs and stuff like that sir or you
know what the best first date location
is it's take her to a painting class one
of the painting core classes so you can
get that on Groupon for like 24 dollars
okay - 442 right Amy you got liquor dear
already they give you a 1/3 glass of
wine
BAM that's super cheap - you get to see
how creative and artistic she is and she
get to see how creative and artistic you
are if you should approach me with hey
beautiful how are you today and
depending on my response he knows if he
can ask me out a lot if I say I'm good
how are you and I smile and maybe he
could ask me out but if I'm like excuse
me who the [ __ ] are you you should walk
away I love it when a man is prepared
there was nothing like a man having all
the essentials and necessities that you
mind me if a man if I my cycle started
in a man had a maxi pad in his [ __ ] I
would be unquestioning but I would use
that next and I'd be like that's a good
man right here he knew when my cycle was
coming he pays attention
or he uses those maxi passes like
absorbent shoe foot you know you can do
that right if you got athlete's foot you
can put a maxi pad in your shoes and it
absorb that sweat and then make a feast
number that's sipped it for you see come
on I love Cologne but not heavy doses of
it you know just put a little spritz
spritz spritz you know and don't be all
the screaming you need okay I think
stand with those office primates like
first off if you got a spray that much
come on you'll see
you probably like some time do you want
somebody to step on in a kissy
then don't put so much come on on it cuz
it tastes Nancy okay you don't want your
dick to taste like alcohol and hibiscus
you want you dick to taste like yes like
just dance so you can spritz the inner
thigh area but don't spritz the date
okay one of the first red flags on a
first date for me and it should be for
anyone is dirty man dirty nails dirty
deep so after they educate give her a
call if you liked it give her a call the
next day at least eight to twelve hours
later
don't be coughing like I made it home
are you okay like or like I can't stand
meaty dudes like don't be needy and
don't see thirsty okay thirst is the
worst
I'll say it again first is the worst
so give you eight to 12 hours and then
don't try to keep her on the phone for
fourteen hours don't be trying to talk
her head off
you know I'm saying I'm trying to get
her to tell you her own life story in
that one conversation that this ass
problem another day that's make it
schedule
that see every woman is a little
different and so you have to just read
the body language but basically if her
cuckoo area is pointed towards you
during most conversations she if her
body language is turned away from you it
should just give you side face when she
talk to you she probably don't really
like she hit you with this she talk to
you like this on a time but her legs
open looking directly at you when she
got her nice clothes but giving you some
of this side right here she looking
directly at your titties riding up
direction she's feeling you but if she's
like something to you like this turn
sideways you know she hit you with this
she kind of always closed off she don't
really want you she just be Nicole with
you cuz you feed that I am NOT opposed
to go see yeah if it's only been two
days or one day and he just disappears
I'm cool with that he wasn't feeling me
by I don't mind but if we've been dating
for like a year here you go
you better be in [ __ ] jail and that's
all I got to say about that don't be
trying to fight nobody
don't be choking people don't let these
two already have these conversations
about year I like a thumb in my butt I
want you to suck on my toe I want you to
nibble on my armpit like [ __ ] like like
unless you hear that conversation
already don't do that don't be slackin
asses and all of that like just do it
regular the first time or whatever maybe
don't we try to stretch people legs like
they Barbie doll the [ __ ] neither don't
we try poor people so like just are you
sure that this member rreeser I don't
like that you'll never [ __ ] me again
I'll keep it 100 you'll never get in
this again like realtalk
have conversations about what you into
see if she into the same thing and me
and got them do like all that kind of
stuff but don't just like we don't have
that conversation we get our instrument
and you start doing weird [ __ ] I'm a
great teacher I probably should have
been a sex education teacher but I don't
feel like taking college classes anyways
I'm out let me take my big dick look I
mean my big penis but I'm finished can
somebody get this microphone get get
this [ __ ] off of me you're not wet [ __ ]
it I'm taking you home
[Music]